bonjour cinéma les Damien paysagiste
aujourd'hui
donc la dernière fois je vous avais
montré comment faire une semi dans une
terrine
et aujourd'hui on va faire le repiquage
donc on va séparer les plans qui ont
poussé dans la terrine pour qu'ils
puissent se développer un à un ça dépend
ça peut prendre en 4 et 5 jours à la
germination l'important c'est que la
plante soit vraiment pas trop fragile
pour le transplanter donc déjà faut le
système racinaire c'est bien développé
afin de faire le repiquage par exemple
ici ici j'ai fait un semis de piment
donc ça fait j'ai semé ça la semaine
dernière la plante a une petite maturité
on peut voir que quand même elle est
assez résistante
pour le repiquage
une plaque à vélo
de la tourbe sur du qu'on a utilisé pour
la semi
le tamis aussi qu'on a utilisé pour la
semi
donc on va faire un petit fond tamisé
voilà
les grèves c'est de la perlite
c'est un engrais à diffusion lente aussi
qui est mélangé à la tourbe c'est les
pépinières qui préparent donc on voyait
quand j'appuie dessus il y a un petit
produit qui sort
donc après avoir tamisé les alvéoles
avec un petit fond de
tourbe on va pouvoir remettre en gros
comme ça qu'on va repiquer la plante en
surface il sera bien stable et sur le
fond ça sera plus fait pour le que les
racines se développent beaucoup plus
vite
voilà
ça sent bien passé au fond
ensuite après le remplissage moi je
conseille le vapo parce que avec un
arrosoir ça ça va faire des trous ça va
ça va abîmer le substrat voilà c'est un
travail minutieux donc
ça demande aussi la précision si on veut
avoir une bonne semence
un bon repiquage
voilà donc
ici j'ai pris une petite baguette
je fais des petits trous à l'intérieur
des alvéoles
vaut mieux prendre son temps et faire un
bon travail qu'à aller vite et au final
après les plans
auront du mal à se développer
et ça servira à rien cette étape
toujours la baguette mais si vous
trouvez une baguette un peu plus fine ça
sera encore mieux donc
aller au fond et soulever
voilà
la folie ça c'est le système racinaire
donc
ici je disposais ici bien centré le plan
et faire un bornage
on sait le bon linge ça sert à
mettre en contact les racines
et la Taube
cette étape est très importante parce
qu'on peut pas transporter directement
les petits plans dans les pots de 13
donc les plans ils sont trop fragiles en
fait ils vont pas pouvoir supporter déjà
l'arrosage et ça va il va se masser il
va pouvoir avoir des maladies en fait
voilà donc
l'étape de la vidéo c'est très important
donc ça fait quelques jours
j'avais pas j'avais transplanté ces
plans là voilà
faudra attendre cet auteur là
pour pouvoir le transplanter
dans le pot de 13 donc ça c'est l'état
final après cette étape là on va pouvoir
faire la mise en terre donc toujours on
va utiliser toujours la courbe
ou même on pourrait utiliser du terreau
normal mais comme on a la toux va
toujours utiliser ça à faire un trou
avec le doigt ici
par contre ici il faudra prendre toute
la motte et le plan avec
voilà
et faire le bonheur
donc c'est la dernière étape donc
ensuite laisser développer bien arroser
surtout et
au bout de quelques temps au bout d'un
mois un mois et demi on va pouvoir le
mettre en terre les étapes sont très
importants mais après il y a des gens
qui prend directement la plante et le
met en terre ça pousse au moment le
risque d'abîmer la plante et
la planche ça va il y aura du mal à se
développer donc au bout d'un mois quand
ça va mettre la plante en terre mais
jette pas le pot donc gars le coup pour
pouvoir
retransmettre les petits plans comme ça
c'est bien le goût mais je vais pouvoir
repiquer repiquer avoir beaucoup de
plans voilà